okay so what we've learned is that we
shouldn't write we you and I shouldn't
be writing the show we should just come
up with ideas yeah yeah so season 4 will
be really good we had always show them
an animatic from season 9 that we wrote
giving cut to the Pentagon a lot of
trouble aren't we no 7,000 senators nod
their heads at a cloaked figure who
presses a red button cut to outside the
Pentagon missiles launched into outer
space
cut to earth the missiles go into outer
space and then and then but they're just
going in outer space because that's
there they didn't they weren't they
weren't like that they're going to land
on things on earth ta and then they go
back that cut to the Rick's neighborhood
missiles rained down on the whole
neighborhood and everything blows up
zoom in on the rubble where Rick's
garage used to be a single blinking
light draws our eye to beneath two
pieces of brick we're a tiny hatch opens
up shrunken Rick and Morty the clamber
out well [ __ ] call that one didn't I
Morty really oh sorry
another morty comes out he's also
shrunken they got i think i cloned you
man one more one more really quick here
I'll do all let me do all the stage
direction real quick great okay you know
you doing okay okay Rick and Morty are
in a candy shop and it's grateful and
colorful I had Morty you're going to
love this candy you're going to love it
it's not got all the college candy in
the world morning we're going to eat all
of it
no Morty [ __ ] idiot so you don't eat
candy with you have you been eating
candy yeah I Benigno oh no accordian is
king idiot oh the can Didion's it hope
you that you eat though oh [ __ ] how long
has it been eating candy Morty oh no oh
this whole time they came giving me free
sample zoom into Morty's blood sugar as
the candy diem revolution begins
[Laughter]
all right let's just do cold open we're
good at that okay faded on a
Thanksgiving planet everything is
grateful dad oh I don't know what that's
my Lisa yeah I'm Lisa Simpson sorry
that's not Lisa Simpsons therefore what
are you reading
well we heard you thankful thankful get
a meteor destroyed them Oh Morty aren't
you glad you aren't down there on that
[ __ ] Thanksgiving planet yeah Rick
why why do you keep taking me here every
year well I I wanted you to see it get
blown up from space also existence oh
that I'm thankful that's right
thankfully we're up in my spaceship safe
from [ __ ] asteroids and the
Thanksgiving planet getting killed
that's a good I got I get it now I am
lucky also Lisa Simpson was down there I
don't know why Oh special Simpsons
crossover episode right one bar called
open a Dark Side of the Moon is playing
on a 17 photograph the whole thing is
shot in the 35 millimeter is that the
thing we pan across cans of empty dog
food empty cans of dog food guy
arriving at a blanket covered in maggots
at a baby courts hey Rick what are you
up to
Morty don't come in here don't come in
here oh my god look I can explain why
are you listening the dark side of the
Marlin that's the issue well I mean yeah
there's a dead baby corpse in maggots
but like Dark Side of the Moon what are
what is this 1970 whatever here that
came out morning give me a hug a
newspaper flies into the window it
slides into frame
the headline and is is Nixon were to
resign oh geez Nix is going to resign
Rick you hear about this ha ha ha Morty
who gives a [ __ ] give me come here come
lay with me in this blanket the two of
them curl up on a maggot covered dead
baby emulsified blanket this is going to
be a good episode all right one more one
I done this for how about fade in and a
beach move from the beach out to the
surface of the ocean and seagulls dive
collecting a fish such as life before
the camera moves down underneath the
ocean and submerges
past various sea life arriving at the
lost city of Atlantis well jeez Rick we
finally made it to the God darn lost
city of Atlantis
yeah Morty mmm can't wait to get in
there and you know whatever see what's
up with that [ __ ] place
oh hell over my dead fish man Robbie oh
[ __ ] Morty it's a [ __ ] see Atlantis
person I'm the skinniest lantus person
hey why is [ __ ] such a piece of [ __ ] I
got to be a dick your people are
responsible for our need to talk well
Lily
fingers over our lives we will never
forgive you I really hope you washed
that hand no can I catch that like it
gross sickness alright one more okay one
more one more
although I love Erica's to picture hope
that you started another chronic she's
trying to rescue boat I hope you're
saving all these layers okay fade in a
digital computer scape okay
Tron world but not copyrighted yeah yeah
totally not notice any lawyer way just
in a romaji oh that kind of seems like
Tron way how they're doing to Tron bit
gleaming light savory highways merge and
none merge as drones and limb locks or
whatever the [ __ ] if they rape linden
lockdown and we arrive at a at the
center hub of not copyrighted Tron world
the master control program and zoom in
on a window has a and revealed digital
Rick I see you're at Disney's Tron world
copyright and wrong in two thousand and
whatever year it came out geez Rick are
we gonna get sued just kidding no a
completely original Tron robe I'm
digital Rick this is completely original
not owned by Disney Tron world coca-cola
of a file enters
hi I love King children can't get enough
of it I'm Pepsi but and I do too
hey you can't children on my watch I'm
coca-cola oh boy we're going to two of
them wrestling site rolling around on
the ground before finding out that they
love each other
Morty Morty wait I just discovered
something about these two characters
they have they could kill us
there's be so powerful that they could
[ __ ] kill us in our sleep we shouldn't
joke about them that's the year we live
in 30 G's you need coca-cola and Pepsi
yeah but their each other now I know
it's Otis they're totally in each other
whether you kill us morning in our sleep
oh my god keep licking season four we
don't know about season four seasons are
might not happen it depends on how much
of the Hot Topic slipper money we do you
think Justin is about our philosophy
about doing like bringing things back
because I think we're doing it right I
don't know I don't think we should bring
anything back unless unless we have a
really really good reason for it we have
we have ought we often sit and we have
those conversations where we're like
well do you do you do another meeseeks
episode where it's just like oh that's
the only reason you're doing it is
because you like the music's and
associate them with pleasure is that and
I'm not asking this rhetorically because
now I don't even know because now I look
back and go [ __ ] do it
well we had we had an episode where we
were going to have the meeseeks beat in
the episode and then it started to fear
in the direction of like well if we're
going to bring the meeseeks back this
has the meeseeks need to be more it
started to become a meeseeks episode you
remember that and then we were like
we're like [ __ ] this forget it abandon
meeseeks and let's stay the course with
this episode well I always said that
they should I mean I should just they
could just come back and the episode
doesn't have to be about town so he use
them like a sonic screwdriver injector I
mean that's what we did we were about to
do that I don't remember what happens
but it was a oh wait I think I know what
episode it was but I mean it would be
spoilery so I'm not going to
alright get into that only Ashok is
smart could be this stupid
Rick and Morty all-new episodes begin
Sunday July 30th at 11:30